we're gonna talk a little bit about
sickling and the point of it and why you
should probably be using it from your on
windows so sig one is just a it's just
like a little Linux terminal pretty much
except it runs on Windows so you can do
all your standard Linux stuff like LS
can see your list of files all I have is
Dungeon Master power right now but if I
go back a directory and do it LS there's
my username I'll go back another
directory there doing LS LS you'll see
you'll see what looks like a some Linux
stuff etc live estimating user home
proktam var and sig Drive so this is
what you get and you can just use it
like you're on Linux which is great for
developers because that's what you need
so let me okay so how do you find this
how do you get it I'll go over that real
quick you basically just open up a web
browser
I've got edge here I wouldn't recommend
use an edge but now I'm using it for
some reason
and you basically just do a search for
cygwin I mean you can go to cygwin comm
sure but if you search on any engine
ever you'll find it it's out there go to
their site and you'll fly in there a
little executable you probably wants a
64-bit one because why not you know in
this day and age so grab that once you
get it
you just run it and you might want to
save it because one thing about this
it's not necessarily that intuitive or
you wouldn't know right off is you
basically run this setup again to
install new applications on the cygwin
and to update cygwin so in in this in
general don't change these options I
mean you sure you can if you want but
I'm just gonna leave them all default I
would recommend leaving them all default
because it keeps it simple you there's
no surprises and you don't forget what
you did and that sort of thing and all
the default options are just funny so
when you run this installer first the
first time you do it it'll install
signaling with all its basic stuff but
as you can see the second time I've done
it here what I get is okay so you have
this view which tells you what category
of apps you're gonna and looking at the
pending right now and I there's a couple
pending just from running at once which
basically means there were a few updates
shows you your current version shows you
the new version and tells you if you're
getting the bin which is the binary or
the actual executable generally or the
source and the source and or the source
so I'm not gonna get the source cuz I
don't need that right now but if you
want to look at the source if you're
that into development that you start
looking at the source of everything go
for it so you Masek adjust hit next and
it will do it but if you want to add on
stuff you go you change this view option
go to the not installed and you search
for what you want
you know I've got most of stuff
installed I already want like I think I
could have like most the GCC stuff or at
least the core stuff but let's do an
example here because I just want to show
you real quick how this works so for
example if I'm interested in getting
let's go down through here a little bit
and find something I can't really think
of anything in particular I need maybe I
want IV I want auto gin and you just
click over here where it says new double
click that tells you what version you're
getting and maybe I want Auto make so
now let's just do all that make I don't
need Auto Jim and you can get a specific
version if you want as you can see
there's lots of lots of Linux looking
apps that you would kind of be used to
seeing if you're if you're doing a
apt-get or a yum install or something
with with an actual version of Linux and
these all tend to work pretty good
doing graphics through cygwin is a whole
other story that I'm not going to get
into but it is possible you can you can
do graphical programming through this I
honestly wouldn't recommend it I
recommend sticking to command line stuff
for tools but that might be another
video maybe it's not as bad as I think
but when I when I did it when I was
popping up windows and doing some stuff
with OpenGL was a tiny bit buggy a tiny
bit slow so I but it did work so there
is that all right so all I chose was
automate and as you can see it
automatically added a bunch of stuff
don't go back for a second here so if
you check one thing hit automatic that
gets everything else you need for it all
the dependencies in it as you can see
it's gonna uninstall my old version of
cygwin and install the new one but it's
also going to add in all this auto make
and Auto config stuff but only check the
one thing only check this but because
all this automatically added oops in the
windows I click this one it's all this
automatically added stuff that is needed
so it handles that automatically you
don't have to really worry too much
about making sure you're getting all the
right stuff and you just hit next and
let it go and has a problem because
cygwin is currently running
I don't think exactly running so I want
to stop the process I think this is just
the uninstall and we installed the new
version probably has to stop it to
remove it of course so we'll let it do
its thing and let's see I could talk a
little more about cygwin but if you
really want to get super in-depth your
best bet might be to just go to their
webpage and do some reading on your own
they have a lot of information here
there's a lot of tips and tricks out
there about things you can do in it but
generally it just it does it's a command
line or Linux it also gives you folders
and stuff okay so this is still doing
this
I just I think we'll just go on anyway
okay
yeah continue is the right option there
and it looks like I might have to reboot
so we'll see how this goes
you need to reboot as soon as possible
okay well I don't really I don't really
want to do that not in the middle of
recording a video so maybe I shouldn't
have done that update just yet
but that's okay well we'll just work
with the old version here okay so the
next point I wanted to go into is there
are some integrations like Visual Studio
code if you haven't installed in Windows
there's a launcher here okay so yeah if
you have Visual Studio code or some
other editor it works fine because you
can you can open folder and go to your
project and basically go to your OS
Drive you go to cygwin and you'll find
home you'll see your user name I put my
username as Cortana don't don't at me
and you'll see your stuff so you can you
make projects and here you can make
folders in here but you can also use
cygwin to navigate through it starts on
your home folder car starts within your
home folder so i'm here what if I just
do a make door of like a test folder
you'll see that it will make another
folder so you can use all these Linux
commands to work with your stuff and of
course you can install anything you want
basically from that little updater that
I ran which is just the setup
so I don't know what else really to say
about it other than that cool stuff I
suppose I could show you a few examples
one thing that's really cool is you can
you can use them in bi and and all those
through here too and you can use of
course SSH to get to your stuff and it's
just nice if you're already used to
Linux and you're forced to be on Windows
for some reason or if you want just a
Linux environment and you're always
normally on Windows so let's just open a
file say we do code main dot C 4 plus
plus plus file so this should open in
Visual Studio code and create the file
database and we save so I don't know
we'll just we'll just do a quick thing
do an int main I'll go to and depth here
and just do it a little world I suppose
a new line at the end of course all
right so now that I've saved it should
show up on my folder windows e to open
folder go to my little OS drive here say
164 there's all my stuff and all my
stuff and a bunch of stuff is now
created you see all my
bash history stuff now and profile file
so that's just part of your terminal
settings don't want about those us so in
case you don't know Linux files I have a
dot in front of them are typically
hidden so these are all actually meant
to be hidden but since I'm in a Windows
File Explorer they're not hidden because
Windows doesn't understand that kind of
stuff so yeah I made my main I saved it
now I could compile it for example
through Linux using GCC and following
check the version of GCC I have I can do
that - be just like it would be able to
home Linux GCC is needed compiler
collection I believe for C++ good new
compiler collection all right guess the
G plus plus is probably what I mean to
be talking about here because that's
what I'm actually gonna compile with and
oh it's the same thing okay
so if I want to compile that I just do
the standard Linux command of doing such
a thing you know it'll come as a a dot
out I do an LS case it what makes an
executable on Linux it's usually an a
dot out in Linux or I said when I pens
the executable to it so if I do a dot
exe with a dot slash in front of it
it'll run it say hello world just like
you would expect on Linux so the great
thing about this is it's not as a
resource heavy as doing using something
like visual studio in the visual studio
compiler clicks that's another another
point all right well I think that's
enough for this video if you have any
questions or something is unclear or you
have any additional tips for cygwin
users or people that want a Linux
environment on Windows feel free to
leave a comment and I'll see you in the
next video keep coding
you